Now that you've seen the two other ways of declaring and
defining objects, let's give them a try by creating two objects,
one using dot notation and the other using bracket notation.
Using dot notation, create an object that contains some of
your work information, including your position, employer, the years worked and
the city of the business.
Then, using bracket notation, create an education object that
includes the school you attended, the years you attended, and the school's city.
>> And how will students know they've done it right?
>> Underneath your objects, append() work ["position"] and
education.name to the resume.
If you did it right, they should show up.